lo que tenemos aquí son 12 dulces los
que están coloreados de café tienen
chocolate por afuera y aquellos que
tienen una c en ellos significa que
tienen coco adentro por ejemplo este que
está aquí arriba a la izquierda tiene
chocolate por afuera pero no tiene coco
adentro mientras que este de aquí tiene
chocolate afuera y Coco adentro mientras
que este otro no tiene chocolate afuera
pero si tiene coco adentro y ese de aquí
no tiene ni chocolate ni coco lo que yo
quiero hacer aquí es encontrar
diferentes maneras de representar esta
información que estamos viendo una forma
de hacerlo es usar diagramas de ven Este
es un diagrama diagrama de Ven y la
convención para dibujar ese tipo de
diagramas es dibujar un rectángulo que
representa el universo de las cosas que
nos interesan en este caso todos estos
dulces y todo lo que haya aquí adentro
de este rectángulo debe ser igual al
número de elementos que tengo afuera en
este caso a 12 porque tengo 12 dulces y
dibujaré círculos para representar los
conjuntos que me interesan por ejemplo
Aquí voy a poner el conjunto de las
cosas que tienen chocolate y en algunas
ocasiones estos círculos se dibujan a
escala dependiendo de la cantidad de
elementos que tienen pero aquí no los
voy a dibujar a escala Este es mi
conjunto que tiene chocolate y aquí voy
a dibujar mi conjunto de lo que tiene
coco aquí lo escribo coco nuevamente
ente eso no está a escala ya que los dos
están más o menos del mismo tamaño Pero
si ustedes observan los dulces podemos
ver evidentemente que hay más con
chocolate que con coco y ahora vamos a
llenar estas diferentes secciones
Cuántos de estos dulces tienen chocolate
pero no tienen coco Tenemos
uno dos tres 4 cco y seis esta sección
de acá Tiene tiene seis y nuevamente
aquí no me estoy refiriendo a todo lo
que tiene color café solo me refiero a
esta área que estoy sombreando en verde
bueno Cuántos de estos dulces tienen
chocolate y también tienen coco pues
vamos a tener uno m dos tres Así que
tres de ellos tienen chocolate y también
tienen Coco y noten que esta sección es
la que se sobrepone en ambos conjuntos
aquí tres dulces caen en ambas
categorías Cuántos son los que tienen
chocolate pues serán 6 + 3 9 Cuántos son
los que tienen coco vamos a calcularlo
en un momento Cuántos tienen chocolate
pero no tienen coco Bueno uno y este uno
representa el conjunto que estoy
sombreando acá en
blanco así que Cuántos dulces tienen
coco en ellos 3 + 1 4 y lo último que
nos falta por llenar ya que vemos Que 6
+ 3 + 1 son 10 no son los 12 del total
de dulces que tenemos pues veremos que
los dos que nos faltan este uno y dos de
acá no tienen ni chocolate ni Coco y
estos los voy a escribir aquí que no
pertenecen a ninguno de estos conjuntos
Y esta es una manera de representar
Cuántos dulces tienen chocolate y
cuántos de ellos tienen Coco y cuántos
no tienen ninguno de estos Pero hay
otras formas de representar esta
información otra forma de hacerlo es
usando una tabla de contingencia
tabla
de
contingencia en el eje vertical digamos
que tiene tiene chocolate abrevio
chocolate con
choco y aquí escribo no chocolate no
tiene
chocolate y por acá escribo con coco es
decir tienen Coco y aquí los que no
tienen coco no coco vamos vamos a
dibujar líneas para separar estas celdas
línea aquí acá y
acá y también líneas aquí aquí y acá
ahora vamos a llenar la información en
esta tabla en esta primera celda voy a
poner aquellos dulces que tienen Coco y
también tienen chocolate y tenemos tres
dulces que tienen Coco y
chocolate aquí dice que tiene chocolate
pero no tiene coco pues es este seis de
aquí el seis verde ahora la siguiente
celda dulces que tienen coco pero no
tienen chocolate con coco y sin
chocolate pues nada más tenemos uno y
finalmente en esta celda van a ir
aquellos dulces que no tienen Coco y
tampoco tienen chocolate y aquí tenemos
que aquellos que no tienen ni chocolate
ni coco son dos y si quisiéramos
podríamos escribir aquí los totales
total de este lado y total aquí abajo y
y mi total vertical es todos los que
tienen coco sin importar si tienen o no
chocolate 3 + 1 cuatro este cuatro
significa todos los dulces que tienen
coco no nos interesa si tienen chocolate
o no todos los que tienen coco de este
lado vamos a tener todos los dulces que
no tienen coco van a ser estos 6 + 2
o ocho y ahora veamos los totales
horizontales queremos ver todos los
dulces que tienen chocolate sin importar
si tienen Coco o no 3 + 6 son nu y aquí
abajo 1 + 2 van a ser tres los dulces
que no tienen chocolate sin importar si
tienen o no coco son tres Espero que
ustedes hayan encontrado interesante
esto pues son diferentes maneras de
representar la misma
información